und bei diesen bildern hat die welt die
luft angehalten das ist gerade mal ein
jahr her weg bloß weg tausende
zehntausende menschen wollen raus aus
afghanistan weg von den taliban den
brutalen islamisten die haben sich nach
abzug aller westlichen truppen das land
ja zurückgeholt unser bild reporter paul
ronzheimer der war mittendrin vor einem
jahr mitten drin auch unter denen die
dann im letzten flieger saßen raus aus
dem land die die flucht geschafft haben
und paul ist jetzt zurück in afghanistan
taliban land bei denen bei den familien
die unter diesem brutalen regime jetzt
leben müssen
michna wir ist 38 jahre alt lebt in
kabul ist vater von fünf kindern
doch ein kind fähig seine fünfjährige
tochter sie wurde verkauft für 360
dollar an seinen bruder
[Musik]
bild vize paul ronzheimer kehrt zurück
nach afghanistan will die geschichte der
hinterbliebenen erzählen
[Musik]
ich habe meiner frau gesagt ich kann
nicht mehr arbeiten ich habe keinen job
wir haben kein einkommen es gibt keine
andere option mehr wir müssen unsere
tochter verkaufen wenn wir überleben
wollen wir müssen das machen wenn der
rest unserer familie überleben soll nur
so konnten wir uns einigen
die eigene tochter verkauft weggerissen
von ihren geschwistern ihren eltern
ihrem zuhause das was für jeden
unvorstellbar scheint ist bitterer
alltag vieler familien in afghanistan
ein jahr nachdem die taliban die macht
übernommen haben
damals versuchten zehntausende menschen
zu fliehen die taliban regime vor einer
hungersnot vor terror und tod viele
afghanen schaffen es doch millionen
menschen bleiben zurück
ein jahr nachdem die taliban kabul
überrannt haben sind wir hier wieder in
der hauptstadt und eines wird direkt für
mich deutlich die humanitäre situation
die ist für die menschen noch viel
schlimmer geworden viele viele menschen
viele kinder viele frauen hungern hier
97 prozent der familien können ihre
kinder nicht ausreichend ernähren mehr
als drei millionen kinder sind
unterernährt
es droht eine humanitäre katastrophe
auch die lage der frauen ist desaströs
eine ausbildung die chance auf ein
unabhängiges leben unmöglich nach der
machtergreifung schließen die taliban
die meisten mädchenschulen viele junge
frauen weichen auf untergrund unterricht
aus fehlende zukunftsperspektiven führen
die frauen in zwangsehen burka kontrolle
häusliche gewalt
michna sie als zehnjährige tochter
familie kümmert sich liebevoll um ihre
geschwister und hilft wo sie nur kann so
wie eigentlich ein traum ist dass
lehrerin zu werden nur wird dieser traum
unter dem taliban regime nie in
erfüllung gehen
[Musik]
finanziert seine frauen die kinder sie
hungern noch immer das geld durch den
verkauf der fünfjährigen tochter es
reicht nicht
[Musik]
ich habe mal einen spaß gemacht um zu
schauen wie meine familie reagiert ich
meinte wir müssten jetzt auch einen sohn
verkaufen meine frau meine töchter haben
angefangen zu weinen und meinten auch
wenn wir verhungern bitte verkaufen
nicht
das mädchen lebt jetzt bei mich nazis
bruder der selbst keine kinder hat er
versichert der kleinen gehe es gut die
geschichte dieser familie die es keine
ausnahme sie steht für die realität
tausender familien des taliban regimes
zerstört das land und dessen menschen
und jetzt live zu unserem reporter paul
ronzheimer nach afghanistan ich grüße
dich paul was für eine schreckliche
geschichte die eigene tochter verkauft
fünf jahre alt was geschieht mit ihr
sei das ist die brutale frage und die
frage die uns natürlich seit diesem
treffen kräht denn eines ist klar es
gibt hier immer wieder
zwangsverheiratung gerade auch von ganz
jungen mädchen das passiert auch in
familien und die ganz logische frage die
man sich stellt wie kann es sein dass
der eigene bruder für diese tochter
bezahlt bzw bezahlen muss wenn er seinem
bruder helfen will wenn er der familie
helfen wird warum hat er ihn nicht
einfach das geld so gegeben ich kann
nicht sagen ob es dort zu sexuellen
missbrauch kommt kommen könnte tatsache
ist dass hilfsorganisationen immer
wieder von diesen fällen berichten dass
eben gerade kleine mädchen hier in
afghanistan missbraucht werden dass es
zu zwangsverheiratungen kommt man muss
sagen das ist dieser fälle von
verkauften mädchen auch schon vor den
taliban also bevor die taliban kabul
überrannt hat gegeben hat aber nicht in
dieser masse und ganz besonders eben
nicht in kabul in der hauptstadt das hat
sonst in abgelegenen provinzen
stattgefunden aber dass wir hier einen
fall in der hauptstadt im zentrum des
landes finden konnten das hat uns
überrascht und also mit experten darüber
gesprochen haben das hat auch diese
experten überrascht sie sagen aber
dieser fall zeigt exemplarisch dass das
ein immer größeres problem ist und dass
das ganze eben im vergangenen jahr
extrem geworden 20 jahre paul haben ja
nicht gereicht da hat es an all den 20
jahren nicht geklappt dieses land
nachhaltig zu einem besseren land zu
einem in unseren augen besseren land zu
machen aber könnten wir in diesem einen
fall was auf den tisch legen und diese
mit lanciert diesen papa 38 jahre alt
das geld geben um seine tochter
zurückzukaufen
wir haben versucht ihn zu unterstützen
und auch sozusagen zu helfen dass er
diese tochter zurück bekommt er ist
jetzt
in kabul momentan die tochter weit weg
wir versuchen dazu helfen sagt dem wir
eben diese familie getroffen haben ob
das am ende klappt kann ich dir nicht
sagen denn ich weiß eben nicht welche
möglicherweise tiefer gehenden gründe
oder wahren gründe dahinter stecken dass
das mädchen jetzt beim bruder ist fakt
ist dass das was dort passiert eben
immer häufiger vor sind die frage
einfach die einem durchs herz gehen
angesichts seiner reportage dort paul
dann lasst uns den kopf nochmal anwerfen
und über das land sprechen ein jahr
nachdem sich die taliban das
zurückgeholt haben nachdem die
westlichen truppen dort ja geradezu
fluchtartig das land verlassen haben was
ist das allererste was dir aufgefallen
ist als du nach so vielen mal zurück in
das land nach afghanistan gekommen bist
was war auf den ersten blick anders
es war erstaunlicherweise ruhig hat sich
aus dem flugzeug gestiegen bin man muss
das vielleicht erklären es gibt wenige
verbindungen nur mit afghanischen
airlines arena und am meer fliegen aus
dubai und abu dhabi das ist die einzige
verbindung ansonsten gibt es nur
landverbindung wir sind dort mit einem
fast vollen flugzeug von afghanen am
flughafen gelandet und es war
vergleichsweise ruhig vergleich zum
letzten jahr aber auch zu situation
vorher man muss eines ganz klar sagen
und dadurch dass die taliban jetzt
selbst an der macht sind hat sich die
sicherheitslage im gesamten land
verbessert es gibt eben keine anschläge
mehr der taliban denn dann würden sie
jetzt ihre eigenen leute angreifen ja es
gibt eine gefahr von außen scale also
von einer weiteren terrororganisation
und es gibt ein widerstandskampf aber
ganz generell ist die sicherheitslage
besser geworden das muss man so ehrlich
sagen aber zu welchem preis nämlich zum
preis der uns hat drückt kann ich habe
gestern um models getroffen frauen die
wir hier noch vor einem jahr gesehen
haben die verstecken sich jetzt in
häusern weil sie nicht mehr models sein
dürfen weil sie nicht auch nicht in die
uni gehen dürfen und was ganz klar
ersichtlich wird die armut im land hat
noch weiter zugenommen sie ist ganz ganz
extrem geworden was auch daran liegt
dass eben weltweit wir dieses regime
nicht anerkennen wollen und das
natürlich auch einstellt wie viel wir
helfen wird und müssen wir am ende doch
sagen nach all den 20 jahren einsatz
dort da dem verzweifelten versuch dieses
land besser zu machen müssen wir jetzt
einfach sagen gut okay solange dieses
land die taliban keine gefahr für uns
darstellen nehmen wir das hin
das ist eine ganz schwere frage die ich
irgendwie aus dem herzen heraus kam mit
ja und mit nein beantworten muss mit
nein deshalb weil so viele menschen hier
unterdrückt werden wie können wir so ein
regime unterstützen wenn eben die frau
nicht zur schule gehen dürfen daran muss
man eher erinnern vor einem jahr wurde
ihnen versprochen dass sie wieder zur
schule gehen dürfen und ein jahr später
eben in den höheren klassen dürfen
frauen immer noch nicht zur schule gehen
also da ein klares nein aus dem herzen
und dann aus meinem herzen ein klares ja
auch denn wenn man die armut sieht dann
muss man sagen wir müssen die menschen
wir zumindest so unterstützen dass sie
überleben können und das ist das was die
meisten menschen hier beschäftigt wie
bekommen sie jeden tag so viel nahrung
so viel wasser dass sie und ihre kinder
den tag überlebt
[Musik]